no
true good afternoon councilors welcome
to this regular meeting of the community
well-being committee for December 12th
I've got apologies from councelor soapa
and Stewart for this if somebody would
like to move that we accept that Evelyn
and Pia thank you put that all in favor
against carried any Declarations of
Interest anybody wants to
make if not we'll move to the
um minutes of the community well-being
held on November
14th we want to move that those uh
um
confirmed Tom and Pia
open for
discussion put that all in
favor against
carried uh members of the public
excluded session of that committee uh
move that they are
received Trish and
grunt any discussion that's part of the
process of those PX minutes coming
forward for confirmation and
open but that all in favor against
carried we've got the minutes of the
district licensing committee and our
activities through November which I'm
happy to move second thanks Peter any
questions if not put that all in
favor against carried application for
grant funding for to the inago licensing
trust stepen welcome
along
always good to make an entrance isn't
it you've seen The Graham Norton
Show uh thank you chair and good
afternoon councilors and M Clark uh I
will take this report as being read
there are a couple of um amendments that
I'd like to note uh one is to the value
of the funding that will be applied for
um has increased to $825,000
and also the inclusion of uh wopi wavy
and Winds of North schools on the list
which had been missed dear I say it
again it's the W's so um I'll open the
floor up for questions so can we just
reconfirm those schools you were adding
there Steven Why hope
I uh we're Hy wavy Park and Winds North
all the W's the W's fall off end the
page a year ago too the same three yeah
what sten indicated
yes uh Grant yeah thanks to so that
represents all the primary schools in
the mle or the license just here at it
does does it yep okay there's no no one
not
there Evelyn um it represents schools
outside the invoc licensing trust area
as well including that was what I was
picking up on um
Bluff Bluff St Joseph's School in uh no
is it no ST teres school and
Bluff um marar Maris B
marara in possibly Tisbury and certainly
or TARTA are all outside of the IL area
so we need to be really careful how we
word this uh yes so they they are
outside the inago license and Trust area
but they are in the inago license and
Trust Foundation
region so that's excellent answer that's
the I think it's actually important that
we make that distinction because um I
nearly raised it last year for the same
reason there's
a perception yeah about where the
licensing trust area is that is raised
by this um and the foundation is a
different creature so we're we're using
Foundation money yes um the majority of
the funding genuinely comes from the
foundation and is topped up by the inago
licensing
trust yeah you so how how widely do we
um tell people about this and the reason
I ask I've had feedback around CET
Splash Palace and you know and the lack
of support around learn to swim and this
is a very clear example of how we are
helping the community learn to so you
know can we snc from the rooftops more
about this to let parents know and
others know that actually we do invest
in learn to swamp programs and we do get
the support of other Comm Community
Partners to make sure that we enable our
kids to use Splash B and other water
facilities yeah um that's that's
definitely we can do that more we can
communicate that more to the public um
there is obviously people who are have
gone through that with the schools would
be aware of the you know how it comes
about um the program has also being a
finalist in the recreation Awards I know
yeah nationally for um couple years now
yeah I just wonder if we can be a bit
more proud of what we do y
definitely Trish then Tom I just like to
say I reiterate what um Grant said and
it's the Envy of other schools further
north you know that we can as a
community get bus our kids to to the
pool and have you know learn some
classes so well done and we certain want
to maintain it we can yes definitely
thank you Tom then
Alex does every school that qualify for
funding
participate yes yes they do some of them
participate at different levels so um if
you take macara for example they've got
their own scoo uh we provide them with a
deep water program uh to come into
Splash Palace uh and do a bit of boat
safety and that sort of stuff yeah okay
thank you Alex um thank thank you um I
guess as a parent with whose child goes
through these um swimming lessons it's
really interesting looking at their PE
where some of them this is literally the
only swimming lessons that they'll ever
see um in their um primary school
lifetime um my question is not really
related to this funding piece per se but
do we have um the rural schools coming
in to do um swimming lessons as well
that run their own programs are they
subsidized by their own communities like
how does I'm thinking like y work and
such or do they end up going into um
rivet and swimming pool yeah um so
generally they probably go into either
rivon or Winton they're managed by
Southern reap which is out of Winton um
but we work alongside Southern reap to
also provide a uh deep water program uh
usually in term four of the Year sort of
AC quiet a period for the IL lessons and
supplemental question sorry do you still
run like the the Royal life saving
programs like you bronze cross and
Silver Cross and all of those sorts of
things we don't as a facility but I'm
sure the um surf life saving that might
do that or if it is surf Li maybe it's
that's the pool one wasn't it yes not
not really seen that much in New Zealand
anymore probably more in
Australia gosh Alex you old thing I
know any further questions
counselors if not there were two
recommendations with
amendment that Steven mentioned so the
amount is up to 182 500 somebody like to
move that Peter Evelyn open for
discussion put it then all in
favor against carried thanks stepen
thank
you right
Caroline we're up to the general
policies Reserve management plan
good afternoon counselors thank you very
much and similar to Steven um I would
like to take the repor as R just to
reiterate a couple of points um the the
reason behind having the general
policies Reserve management plan is to
set the objectives and policies common
to all of our reserves administered by
inago city council that's all 162 of
them to enable that consistent approach
to our management decisions and
compliance with the reserves act across
all of them um it becomes the foundation
management plan from which all of our
other specific management plans are
drawn from to uh get to this point we
did undertake a two-month consultation
period uh the hearings were were held on
the 7th of November and following those
submissions incorporating what we heard
there um we pretty much factored into
the final um final management plan that
you've got in front of you virtually all
of those changes and suggestions we
heard from the
public Caroline can I just ask does that
include some of the questions around
disability access that were raised in
the act of South and submission
absolutely yeah we um where Poss we
we've incorpor ated all of their
suggestions thank
you questions counselors
Tom carine this is not a changed one so
it's um I don't know how long it's been
there but can you just clarify for me if
you look at
7.7.2 what it refer to which is you
don't really need to look up you you'll
know it it's the dog control one um and
where it says uncontrolled animals are
not permitted on Reserves does that mean
that in all our reserves we dogs
required to be on the leash no no um I'm
pretty certain Jillian would be able to
give me the correct wording but um under
effective control is does not mean on a
lease you can be under effective control
without being on a leash because the
policy would have to take into account
those off leash areas that were
specifically ID the um the dog control
bylaw itself specifies those actual
places where dogs need to be leashed
this just means effective control to try
and cover all of those areas without
being specific within this management
plan um because we were duplicating what
was said in the bylaw in that case okay
thank you as distinct from a dog that's
free
wandering I think I just made up a term
thank
you grant yeah um are there any sort of
changes or amendments in here that are
going to affect current
use no not not that I'm aware of it it
was an amalgamation I mean that's what
we we tried to do with this to pull into
all of the other areas that had
specifics just to try and make sure that
we had one document that was clear for
the community and ourselves to work with
so you'll guarantee that we won't in
three months or six months don't be
hearing the public say or because of
this change in regulation and use is
nowed it should it should be better
should be better for them there's no
anticipated specifics where we could see
that happening councelor good thank
you thank
you Alex um thank you um just around the
filming and photography on public land
and and the says at s um1 0.1 that
commercial filming requires permission
from Parks and R manager now at the
moment um you know like you've got
people that will be able to that can fly
a drone if they get special permission
from the um Airport tower and such over
Queens Park and over our natural assets
and that kind of thing and then that's
used in like Regional promotion or any
kind of you know some commercial
activity that we putting out to um I
guess entice people to move to the
region or for you know those sorts of
activities or also used in um you know
you've got people that will rock up for
weddings and do their wedding
photography on um recreational or
Reserve Land this here does that
prohibit them from doing that no it just
is please ask please ask yeah and that
enables us to ask the question have you
undertaken the CIA regulations as
required for drone so it it's a it's a
catch yeah it's a catch to make sure
that the other regulations are basically
addressed yeah um on that then the
administration of that seems might be a
little bit heft or is it like an on case
basis like would you uh establish a
relationship with the particular
photographer or photographic entity
where um you already know that they are
aware of the CIA qualifications and they
therefore for they obtain the permission
once or do they have to obtain
permission consistently and regularly
cuz you know I'm just thinking that
there are hundreds of photographers and
not only commercial photograph graphers
but hobbyists and such so um how do we
how do we make sure that that's not
honorous on um on them but also on you I
mean it is every time at the moment and
at the moment it's not it's it's not
owner us we aren't receiving that many
um applications right now and if I'm
right it's under review UAB yeah um I
might then suggest that that might be
that the people aren't aware of the fact
that they need to get in contact CU um
if you're not getting that many requests
it means they must not know about it
just by the sheer volume of people that
um undertake that
activity they may not be undertaking
over a reserve
yeah nonetheless if someone's flipping a
drone up in Queen's Park without seeking
permission you have to get they they
actually don't launch unless you've got
the mission y yeah they're locked yeah
but people don't realize that applies
for the likes of Donovan Park as well if
someone's flying I'd like them to be
approved before they're spying on
me any other questions councilors Evelyn
was that a scratch or a hand up no it's
a hand up thank you where you go um yes
thank you Mr chair um Caroline just
there's a couple of um typos that I
might draw to your attention um but
leaving that aside and following on from
what um Council CRA was um
asking is this trying to make the
permissions
process um
no back
track not all the lands that are
considered to be reserves in South in
Vago are city council some of them are
dock land is this some what of a sorting
out the weight from the chaff because
you do need to have permission from the
Department of Conservation to film
within the conservation state do some do
you get some queries that are actually
not on La Land but pertaining to the
conservation estate cuz sometimes people
don't know the
difference um it's a bit of a detailed
answer that I probably would have to
come back to you on Evelyn if that's
okay
um I would think of bluff Hill would be
one of the only places that we would get
to have to cover um the application
would cover both both areas both Doland
and our own I may have seen one of those
in the last couple of days it's why it's
at the top of mind
yeah that that's probably the only
location where that would be occurring
on a frequent basis so if you got one
and they hadn't applied to the
department you would we check you'd
check we' check yeah yeah thank you for
that may Clark um two issues Caroline um
do the easy one first which is section
11 21 which talks about smoke for vaping
and it leads into it by saying the
government has set a goal to make new
Zeal smoke free including including
vaping vaping by 2025 I think the
coalition government is moving away from
that if I'm if I'm honest so that may
need some
clarification um and the other issue is
the it talks about ICC policy on smoke
free now I understand the CBD smoke free
but I'm not sure that we've designated
parks and reserves were done way before
the CBD yeah I understand it but if you
referring to parks and reserves and
you're referring to an ICC smoke free
policy which is what they talk about the
11211 all right if are we saying that
nobody can Vape in a park as well
technically yes but it's a policy not a
bylaw since there is a guideline that we
can't go along and
enforce for example speaking from
experience Saturday morning school boy
football saying to somebody who has
either been having a cigarette or a vape
on the sideline hey do you realize that
the parks are smoke free and vape free
and just before moments before the
second where they get really hot and say
could you just go and stand over there
so you're not right next to the kids or
getting some exercise and suddenly
people become pretty reasonable so it's
just it's it's there as a trigger for
people to be able to have a conversation
to say could you just step back from
from where there are other
people we can't come along and
arbitrarily move people along or forbid
them because it's only a
policy so I guess I'm just trying to
clarify is there a differential between
smoke and vaping or are we including the
two as
one yeah we're including the two as one
there two as one okay so I take it
you'll have another look once we get
past 100 Days with the
government if they are not pushing that
would we still maintain that position do
you think the proposed government law
change has nothing to do with our policy
so even before that have been signal we
can decide what we want as a policy to
the council yep if the if the government
choose not to make the whole country
that way that's that's fine but if
people are on our parks and reserves or
in the CBD we can still say y please be
considerate of others that's what I was
suggesting um with weather we would
still take that pathway regardless of
what the government changes and I guess
the other area that sticks out for me is
we've got a CBD that's also smoke free
and every lunchtime without exception I
see people vaping an air street it's
like the Kingston fire some days isn't
it it's it is and I
just whether we set our parks and
Reserve people up for a standard that
we're not prepared to enforce or
encourage at right in the middle of CBD
yeah okay it's the same scenario I guess
MCL and both the CBD and reserves but it
does enable people just to say could you
be a bit more
considerate okay so the other issue is a
much wider issue around Master plans so
you've heard me say before Caroline
um and I've had discussion with Rex
recently about this um the lead into
this was that this document is I guess
uh underpinned by the reserves act now
the reserves act does not require a
master plan fact The Reserve Act is
quite clear it basically says if you
inherit some land or you you designate
some land as a reserve you have an
obligation within six months to advise
the minister of your management plan and
then the mandators to continually review
that management plan now the word
continue is not defined in the ACT it's
left open to interpretation and I guess
that's quite a good thing because if you
think about some of our reserves you
might only look at them every 10 years
other ones like Queens Park and Sandy
Point you probably look at them every
year um but I just wonder why we confuse
our overall policy when I read through
this in fact in one stays there the
master plan that's referred to and
policy is actually bracketed with the
word development plan which is something
new you yet again and I I just I'm not
trying to be silly about this I'm just
trying to suggest that if we lead into
we should say that our obligations are
management plans which are requirement
when you first get a a piece of reserve
and that we constantly manage that but
in in in some cases we will have an
overarching management plan which is not
required by the ACT but it's smart
business for us to have a long-term
Focus you wouldn't want if you think of
Sandy P Sandy as an example to be
looking at that every year you do need
to have a 10 15 year 20 year look I've
heard suggestions of 50 years which it's
probably too far but um to have that
Forward Thinking um piece of work
because you're not just knee- jerking so
I think in the Preamble if you were of a
mind I think that would be helpful to
clarify that so people are not confused
about it
okay not thanks any comment Caroline
bricks thank
you um k i just just wanted to pick up
on page 68 around the crment and we we
talked about this around just standard
counseling and I know this is reserved
type thing I'm just wondering you know
um within this
policy do you think we need to probably
strengthen it a bit given that there is
a lot of encroachment on reserve
Lane I mean because this is really loose
inst still fences or barriers when
necessary protect we say ensure
processes regarding encroachments on
resered land are
managed are they managed
sorry they they have been managed in the
past so it's um it it enables us to
manage them as when we we find them and
and need to do something with them it it
enables us it's an enabling document I
know it's an enabling document but how
do we s of um yeah without the document
and the policy or the plan you couldn't
manage
thanks any other
questions council is there a a raft of
recommendations there on pages one and
two is someone prepared to move
them I'll second it to get it under way
open for
discussion no um this comes back to what
I said before so uh recommendation six
says adopts the
draft um General where does the draft
go does it go through the council or
does it go through
to public submission which we've already
had I
guess
to council so and just trying to
understand the process here so if the
staff don't agree to having some sort of
oversight at the beginning of the of the
policy around Master plans um if they
just remain silent or didn't have any
clarification would be be back at square
one at the at the council stage if
Council has had a wish for that would it
be sorry you have a crack there well no
I'm just trying to understand if this
committee adopts this to then send it to
councel for
approval um then it will be this
committee that's adopted it without
reference to the master plan that you're
talking about it can be relitigated by
the council at that council meeting if
the council chooses to then re re
address or reassess that particular
matter
okay comfortable with that uh well it
just gives me a clear St that I don't
agree with it so I'll have to vote
against it
y excellent thank you any other Evelyn
so given that um I have got one or two
spelling and grammatical concerns um can
I address that between now and the
council meeting with does that start
with the general Manger
I couldn't possibly comment on the
things that I have cover but they're
mostly minor um I don't think it's worth
raising in this I would con and I'm
pleased that that particular one doesn't
appear on your new name plate
R well I can't see it trust no it
doesn't thank you
Tom I'm not sure whether this is
discussion or question that I forgot to
ask before but um if I look at the 6.11
non-conforming
use and given that we are at the same
time developing the 10year Sandy Point
plan which is get issues you know we're
discussing about non-conforming use by
by adopting this today does that close
any options for that other issue not
that other issue because there is a
specific management plan for the area
that you're thinking of
right thank you thanks good
clarification is there no other
questions it has been moved and seconded
I'll put the motion all in favor sorry
Caroline just before that was gee that
was by a hair's breath so um your
recommendation three endorse the
hearings report it's actually endorse
the hearings which occurred on the 7th
of
November thank you so you don't have the
hearing report there 7th of
November not October yeah so it's the
hearings which occurred the report um
was actually heard on the 7 report
written of the 7th the hearings were on
November 7th yeah yes thank you with
that Amendment or adjustment correction
call it what you will I'll put the
motion all in favor I against yeah I'm
noted
that
carried that brings us through to uh uh
item nine which is the Queens Park
reclassification um and we had the
submitter speaking to us earlier on
there are recommendations to council
there but it's it's
really uh in our hands
um
before before I launch into perhaps some
responses from the hearing Carolina is
there anything you're wanting to add at
this
point um you obviously spoke at the
start of the hearing around um probably
amending that recommendation for to be
um to just reward that
slightly so recommendation four was
changing to one
moment find
these K
Darren so if I can recommend a word
change for uh number four um as just a
couple of inclusion of words to avoid
any perception of predetermination from
from this that if the objections are not
to be accepted it is for the following
reasons K it thank you thank you
excellent thank you took me a second but
I found
it thanks um
so with the uh submissions that you
heard this
afternoon
um just to kick off the the
deliberation what I heard from two of
the principal objectives was that they
opposed the reclassification because
they wanted other activities to be
happening so for
example um that they believe that the
reclassification shouldn't happen
because the museum Redevelopment
shouldn't
happen there were also comments about
separating Museum and and art gallery um
that's not actually a matter for this
Comm
to um
consider um and it would be fair to
summarize that the previous Council had
gone
through the assessment of
renovating the pyramid and the cost of
that versus new builds quite extensively
I guess the idea that was floated by Mr
Simpson this afternoon of it becoming a
community Hub is well and good I've not
had with the exception of the group that
we heard from afterwards suggestions
from anyone within the community that
needs to come forward nor do I see
whether there's a gap and funds in in
our projects for for that to happen so
I'm in my mind it's not something that
I'm open to considering but um that's a
personal
view councilors it's over to you uh if
you have feedback questions or comments
you'd like to make I'm interested in
hearing from them Evelyn and then Trish
and May Clark uh yes Mr chair
look I neglected to
see that the pavilion's lease expired on
the 30th of November so I wish to say
that what I said about not affecting
people on Christmas does not apply
because clearly they are not legally
attendant still um however um that
said I felt overall that apart from that
group and the Heritage Rose group that
there wasn't a great deal of um
awareness of the or adherance to the
principles of why we were having a
hearing um so that concerns me because
we all came and gave off our time for
that purpose and that wasn't the purpose
that we actually listen to so I was ose
it's it's public um exercising their
right to um to speak to us but it would
have been helpful if it was more on task
um and so what I got from that is that
um the issue of the use of the
space um
for the tennis club purpose which is no
longer really relevant was not really
addressed in the submissions and I'm a
little bit uncomfortable about that I
would have liked to have heard more
where the people were intensely
disturbed by the loss of a tennis club
than
um the use of the Pavilion for other
purposes or
um any of those other worthy comments
that we did
hear I hear and share your frustration
although
I think there was a loose but moderately
valid angle that it was put forward with
moderately
um which is why I entertained some of
the discussion because they did give a
reason for objecting to the
reclassification uh it was tenuous at
best um and certainly I'm aware through
a lot of the work that was done with
previous iterations of a Redevelopment
that there were a lot of conversations
with the inago tennis club around
outdoor um uh courts the majority of
their being on Duke Street um and that
the Queens Park courts were seldom used
and they had done nothing in the way of
resurfacing for competition I think it
had been used for uh tennis coaching and
I'm not aware of anybody after the late
Peter white who has used it for tennis
coaching uh P past two years ago now so
and even then he' res resorted to using
um
studium um but yeah take your points
trash um I think you've been too kind
really I felt it was um an inadequate
submission and my opinion um they didn't
really come to address the issue I felt
they came with their own agenda um I've
seen many people playing tennis on the
boys high Courts at weekends and so I
believe the submission doesn't have
validity um I would like us to seriously
consider the other two points by The
submitters Who went out of their way to
support us and brought valid points as
that we would like to um consider um one
for the cultural group perhaps we could
extend the lease over the period of time
until we're ready to use I don't know if
that's possible um and the idea of water
IRG
was very sensible for them to bring it
to us at this point yeah good point I
mean like I I said it wasn't really
something that had to do with the land
reclassification but parks are here and
have heard it and they made a really
valid point that if you're doing a lot
of ground work at the time not a bad
opportunity to to put uh put something
in
lby two things one is the uh not sure
about the wording of of four again it
doesn't leave the door open for somebody
to say at this meeting that they
actually supported the objectives so I
think at the very fron it should say um
to agree or disagree with the objectives
objections and then go on to say if the
objetives are not support are are not
supported these are the reasons why I
think that would be
helpful doesn't three off you that you
the saying whether you agree or disagree
or allow or not accept or not accept it
is but this was a
predetermination this is what I'm
worried about that this was drafted and
notified 4 days ago and I want us to be
really clear that we've realized it's a
bit of an error in the wording and just
make it really clear that if some member
and it's not me wants to agree with the
uh um the voice that said that we
restart the museum um okay so with the
way that I'm holding the discussion now
I'm leaving it open for that so we're
having a discussion without actually
having a motion on the table which sure
technically isn't correct but that's so
I can leave it open for people if they
wish to express those things to do so
now and then we can look at amending um
any of those recommendations that are up
there if those proposed amendments are
supported um and then put
it r I'm looking at um 4B and I'm taking
from the um Rose Heritage um submits
that um concerned about the actual wall
um and the English Field of the RO Gard
Gard should not be um dramatically taken
away but they were open to
recommendations that some of that wall
could be removed in small areas um be is
sufficiently vague that that could still
happen
yeah doesn't prevent it
no understand
that a support where they com from and
having that open that things oh yeah I
agree it was great to hear that because
they could easily have sat there and go
no don't touch the wall that's
right are there any other points or
concerns MCL um the issue about about
the the rooms about the sorry about the
rooms
themselves that the cultural group use
the tennis
club I'm not clear going forward and
Caroline might be able to help and I see
Lee's not here Grant might be help do we
actually need the rooms to be demolished
because one of the things that we'
considered when we initially asked was
that we would future proof that end of
the tennis court so that if we I don't
know wanted an art gallery there in the
future or whatever that we had we were
making the change of classification all
in one go so what I'm saying is that if
we if we change the classification does
that then mean we have to demolish the
old Tennis Club rooms and if the answer
is no to that we don't need to then they
could say Caroline um we have been
working with the pmo office obviously to
ensure that the the schedule of work
that they have can be undertaken and
they require to be in that area and
there will be demolition occurring from
late January okay so that is one of the
reasons why we had um ended the lease
initially in ended in June and then we
actually extended that to November when
we had a bit more schedule of the of the
um
development um we more recently said
please could they be out by the 20th of
December um but we can I've just been in
con uh consultation with the PM office
just now um 15th of January would be the
latest but we are still open to working
with them to try and help find an
alternative venue bearing in mind that
actually they're occupying the space
grus
and we have been doing so up to now
great okay so it doesn't formally make
part of the process but absolutely was
part of the concerns that were raised
through it so thanks that Alex um on
that note I'm happy to agree that the
objections not be accepted and move that
as of case as of what's up on the screen
so you're moving everything with three
saying um to agree that the objections
not be accepted oh sorry that's four yep
yep
as as the discussion has has been
held um so the reserves classification
then in three uh would be
allowed accepted that way continue that
that warning is not right J allowed or
accepted accepted because it would have
to be the
D commissioner or whoever it is that
would allow us accepted and appropriate
um reclassification be
sought so we would not strike accepted
we would strike allowed M
accepted
and appropriate reclassification sort
yeah thanks for your Indulgence that's
why I wanted to work through it this way
sorry I can't hear you
r approp no we're seeking the
reclassification so it has to be
approved by the
minister so appropriate reclassification
sort Council llo um we do have a small
update on that Chris is just going to
read something out that we' just had
recently thank you um in between the
paper going and coming to today only if
it's good news yeah Chris no
pressure through chair uh recently we've
received information from uh minister of
conservation uh Council Under The
Minister's delegation can complete this
process without further involvement uh
from the commissioner under Section 241
and 242 uh so we're in a position now
where we need to inform the commissioner
uh we no longer need to con go the
process for their approv go straight to
the commissioner now that's point six
it's the benefit of pre-engagement with
the commissioner uh when we're
undertaking any reclassification of
Reserve status great you can have a
metaphoric high five for that one I'll
take any high five thank you as long as
it's
open so thank you with that
wording we had a move in seconded did we
pleas thank you any other points Noby so
given this report
which in some ways determines that we've
got a process to work through and the
staff are now advising that that process
is streamlined does this report need to
say that because I mean the community
need to know that actually some good
news here I'm
updated I'm not sure that it that it
does there is just simply the process at
some point we would have to have applied
to a commissioner That's Just Happening
sooner so we have pre-engaged the
commissioner and they've come back to us
so Point number six to your point Noby y
uh currently states to request approval
from the minister yep uh and we could
change that wording to say to inform the
minister thank
you I will second thanks
l
cool any other adjustments don't think
that wording is going to be quite
accurate I think there's something
missing inform the minister ofation to
reclassify
that
reclassification
of part of
um has been agreed to
by
city is that right I'm not sure it
is so Chris what did the the note from
the conservation staff
say Council Under The Minister's
delegation can complete the process
without further
involvement from the commissioner under
Section 241 and 242 however Council must
inform the department of a full
resolution right so that's the inform to
inform the Department of Conservation
that city council has resolved to yeah
great thank
you anything else Noby come back to it
again so people looking at these minutes
4 days ago and now looking at them again
need to understand the process that
we've gone through I think that would be
helpful now it may not be a
recommendation here but somewhere along
the line we need to publicly announce
we've got pre-approval or whatever it is
because I mean one of the questions that
will come up and you know where it'll
come up from is it is did we have that
pre-approval before Thursday and does it
make the submissions we had today a bit
High School Chris can answer that
quickly when did that message come uh so
that message was from the material that
we provided the Department of
Conservation me that we triggered 241
and 242 yes sorry when did they send
that
message we get
response not got that in front of you
don't have that in front of me okay Rick
to to address the M's um comments which
I think are valid we could have a
resolution that is passed as part of
this package of resolutions to
note what's in that what you've just
read out so to note the advice from the
minister or the ministry or Department
of Conservation
is yeah and then that then
formally um has got it on record that we
are we are doing this or you as a
counselor resolving this based on the
advice noted from the Department of
Conservation so it's so number five
might be to note U uh advice from the
Department of
Conservation States and then read that
but out that then becomes part of a
formal resolution so that really is the
rewording of five that you're looking at
there two correct to that point Alex
thank you Mr chair to that point I
actually do understand the mere
sensitivity around this we don't want to
be seen to look like we have had any
kind of predetermination when it comes
to um the hearings this afternoon um
which is why it's really important to
note that that information has been
received after the fact and after we've
only just heard it now so when it comes
to making that decision or moving the
motion we haven't actually been informed
while we've been making it yeah um it
has form part of the formal record of
this this meeting it forms part of the
formal record now yeah we are in public
but I guess in moving this motion I'm
comfortable and my comfortability
centers around the fact that five five
people only five people submitted on it
there's a community expectation that we
just actually get on and get you know a
shovel in the ground around this I think
it's also important to note that two of
those were supportive of it you know
they they're either relocating or just
protecting the taonga that we already
have an existence there
um and the other two weren't you know
didn't really quite hit the mark and
we're talking about things that we've
already made substantial decisions on so
I'm super comfortable that we can
continue with this and I think too that
there's there's possibly also a
reasonable degree of consultation
fatigue around the museum correct um
because people are thinking that haven't
you already done that yeah um we have
whereas this is actually just about the
reclassification of the land rather than
project 1225 yeah which is on its own of
course okay worth those amendments we
have a mve in a second
then there doesn't five need to Beed
done right uh technically five does not
need to change sorry I've got it coming
in several directions at the moment the
way uh so we will still be ratifying the
reclassification by informing them so
technically it doesn't need to
change but to answer the m point which I
think is very valid my advice would be
to note yeah what is in that advice from
the minister or minist or department and
we need a separate resolution then
between five and six to note that advice
that's been received from the Department
that then appeases or or deals with the
the um sensitivity and has a formal
record then that Council can refer back
to if you were challenged in your
decision making process as the M I'm
happy to so we knowe that the late
advice from the minister
of
conservation and what it is you actually
just quote it back to I haven't seen the
I haven't seen the information can you
bring it up Chris just so that Liz can
see
it show the present
comfor
men Christmas flavor to to the
motion good
Christmas the Minster not the
minst just let that one go at the
moment
least that's the advice of the group
[Music]
manger well that's going to
stick
manger manger it goes to the previous
report yeah yeah
M the tree at Christmas time that's how
you spell career this is the
group
mang the world will be in
trouble
you'd be feel inspired to be
rebellious oh
no I think it's it shows you how much we
actually don't realize how much we
compromise ourselves you know
um
yeah I
went been fting
for father came from
um it'll come to
me anyway um
and I and I just realized how
comfortable it is when you're around
your own and you don't have to Justify
Your Existence so even though I'm at
home I still feel like I have to
justify yes it's it's it's a quite
different feeling to feel validated
yeah was what
was it's going to give you a red L
again are you
right-handed I if I
see I
after
see all
yeah what you're
say
yeah oh sorry no photos I just get to
start hand drawing everyone
right everyone's had
um ample time to to have a look at
that slow process of it going
up you're
welcome any questions is anybody not
clear
around
Caroline um third line down on number
six you've got further involvement it
says form not from
from thank
you you just changed it pi to the exact
same thing it's mean to say for isn't it
no
from head form Minister said they don't
need any more involvement yeah um sorry
I've just noticed one more Li
241 and 24
two did you I thought you wanted to
quote
the I'm sensing raspberry lamington at
this
rate and a lot of
them anyone else somebody want to do an
interpretive
dance excellent
answer Mr Che you shouldn't issue
challenges like that I don't know right
now I'd have appreciated a
per
um just before I put it to the vote that
was a crucial piece of information and
it really would have been good to have
had a heads up about that before coming
in to to make the decision
thanks um if I were running a resource
consent hearing I would be saying the
same thing in Sterner
words councilors I'll put the motion all
in favor I I
against carried unanimously thank you
for that thank you in the spirit of the
season I feel an
Allelujah that brings us to the
activities reports and I will leave it
at your discretion to raise the various
areas in which you may choose to ask
questions but I'll give you a
moment
Ellen yes uh Cher just looking at page
167 of the gold books activity reports
noce that the litter
complaints are higher this year than
last year they've gone from 1 to
four it surprises me that there's only
four considering that the L we see on
the streets out Caren Road um West
plain's School Road just thought
I'd mention that and
uh wondering if any of those complaints
do uh pertain to that that area
so Jillian I'll get you to come forward
um I guess it's some complaints that are
reported as well rather than just
general letter which is obviously much
higher Jillian I could comment on uh the
areas that of the complaints so I can be
specific as to if they include West
Plains Road I could check that though um
and we rely very much on the public to
actually report the letter complaint so
this is this is the number of RS RFS
that we've received for L complaints so
that's like fly tipping and the like
when people notic there been rubbish
dumped yes do you have a question around
that was what I was going to raise was
this there's a difference between um
just general General letter and fly
tipping when I I assumed that this was
fly tipping I don't know why um my mind
works that way um
but generally speaking if it was just
general litter would it appear in this
report like
that if it's been reported as an RFS for
literal fly tipping for our followup
then it would come into this report yes
wouldn't matter just depends on if
someone's complain it's complain manage
just litter complaints you I mean
there's a lot of litter around that's
not obviously dropped in a bag or
dropped off somewhere Ellen if no one's
complained about it it doesn't sit on
this
file that is not to say that there's not
a lot of letter out there because there
is it's okay for us to complain as well
we can we
can just as a citizen and the other
thing I going to talk about is the
parking complaints do we have an issue
with parking complaints with the number
having doubled in the last year again
this has been consistent over the last
several months where the number of
parking complaints is considerably
higher than the same month for the
previous
year uh we've been reviewing the data
each month and consistently we have a
lot more
complaints for the same month this year
compared to last year in the suburbs so
generally I think what we're finding is
that people are a lot less tolerant of
um vehicles in the suburbs parking in
areas where it's deemed to be not
appropriate or where they feel that the
car might be abandoned CL supplementary
so so it's not really because people are
not understanding the meters in town or
anything like that no right I thought
that's what it might have been
Grant then r no no asked okay Grant then
Trish yeah well I'm happy to get as
Trish as yours related to cuz I'm okay
thank you um yeah a couple of three
things firstly well done to the um Team
around the Halloween
um not commemorations but the do they
had in the park for Halloween was all
dist Stampy yeah I didn't go myself but
I did see in there but
um you sure it was
no but um a lot a lot of people went to
it and it was a fantastic event and
really great to see air park being used
and you know a different way it was
awesome so we uned couple of things we
just um projects that are going on
within Parks um so I think Sor Park the
bluff mountain bike facility and then
also
um
the um the car park at Bluff how how are
we getting oversight of those projects
in terms of progress against plan budget
those sorts of things Caroline are you
able to answer
that or Rick sorry no is shaking his
head I'll have to take it back and ask
Caroline's there sorry yeah I'm still
here I was hiding behind the
pillar the oversite for S Park is
actually comes through the um ltp
strategic
projects so the site and the funding um
project updates come through your
finance committee so we feed into the
project for um ranna's reports that go
through
there and the the bluff Hill we've been
reporting that through um the action
sheet on the bluff community board and
they have just recently asked for a more
specific update which we'll be giving
them at the next report uh the next
meeting and the
C that's part of the um active
Recreation Hub yeah that's part of the
active Recreation Hub the car park so
it's the first stage
of yeah the tracks and the car par it's
it's one project okay okay so
so it would be good to be able to see
that
through um you know either this
committee or um the Projects B cuz it's
a big spin it's over $2 million is it
not
it's just under $2 million I thought it
was
2.4 but anyway so be good to have
overs
Rex Mr chair so
Council perhaps suggesting it goes to a
different
committee for for that oversight well
either or where wherever is best I mean
so it's coming to yours at the moment
then no the BL one's not
not
infrastructure
or sorry chair or is it the type of
information you're getting report that
is getting reported or not getting
reported yeah I I just think we need to
see where are we at around you know
similar to we see through financing
projects if use the same format comes
through this committee I don't see it
matters which committee but I think it's
important to you wanted on an activities
report well but yeah in the same
structure as we've got in finance a
project y because it's a consistent
thing councilors get used to it and can
see where we're out with budget if
there's any sort of things that are
evolving that we need to be aware of I
think it's just good for us to see those
important projects in our community
reported through thank you not we'll get
it on to the activities report thank you
Trish I'd just like to acknowledge the
good work that's been done in the Civic
C worked hard to um get that moving more
people coming in and and it working
better and the comments reflect that so
that's well done thank you Evelyn um yes
similarly and also um just the continual
uh impression that I get of upgrading of
um furniture and all those sorts of
things it's looking a very smart place
um just to the um lost the place
now the South Museum and art gallery
trust
board so um I'm not sure if this is the
place to say it um but
I don't actually think you're going to
be getting many reports from us in the
future however to this
committee they have a new chair they
have a new name so the new chair of the
South Museum and art gallery trust
board
toaa Southern Regional collections trust
is David Hall Jones and I'm the deputy
chair and and I imagine that now that
items are transferring from nior to
tanif TOA T
um that our reporting will be scaling
down thank you I'm sure you'll enjoy the
light of
paperwork it'll just be moving it from
one place to
another any other items from the
activities report anybody wishes to
raise before I move that we receive it
me
cl range of them range of them um just
going on what Grant was saying I think
um we haven't done enough um positive
comms on the bluff Mountain tracks um I
even hear people from Bluff saying it's
not really for us as for others um which
is disappointing um and I know it's the
end of July it'll be done but we should
be getting on the front foot now and um
getting some coms out and maybe some
pamphlets out to say what's available so
that people as they start to plant
Hollows down in the middle of the year
uh start thinking about there's some
excellent tracks here for them to ride
over um if you use the um Central taret
model that's what they did um and
they've got some really good tourism
because of it um but I still think as a
wider part of that whole development
down there we still have an awful lot of
work to do on Bluff because um um I keep
saying it where do you get a coffee and
Bluff at the moment um we don't we don't
have enough motor home parking
facilities in Bluff which is part of the
attraction for the hill as well
um and in the report that came through
on the Southern Museum and art gy trust
board it talks about uh
the which is a fancy word for getting
rid of some of the stuff that we
currently hold and I'm just wondering um
I've not heard but I would like to know
some along the line when we fully open
up um to
how many staff will be down
there and how many staff will go back to
the new Museum when the new Museum and
will the need to um remove part of the
stuff that we hold there is that a a
shortterm staffing need now Darren you
probably know more than anybody about
this but I pass that back you pass it
back but it would be helpful T know I
think um from my perspective um I
certainly couldn't comment done anything
operational RS do you have any idea at
this point you Mr chair um it is on my
work program um to consider through the
um the start of the next calendar year
um and to take into
consideration um the time frames related
to the development at Queens Park in
relation to also the the program of work
at the storage facility so it is noted
um here and we'll keep you in the loop
yep that be great um three or four other
things cheer um I I struggle to
understand the social media summary
reports on page 186 and to that end I've
sought some independent advice which
I'll present the next time we have this
committee meeting because depends on
where your independent advice comes from
and how independent it is well that's
okay but I'm I'm prepared to throw the
throw some of the figures out there to
say what does it actually mean it
doesn't doesn't stack up with the advice
I'm getting and I look forward to
challenging that yep that's it's all
good
um on the Civic Theater there was a
mention there about Draculas and so this
race is an issue which I've discuss with
Rex given that he's five minutes in the
job yeah I went to that show and I sat
and some seats up in the first layer up
and the very front row Circle A yeah A1
2 and three we had I couldn't see
probably 80% of the stage because the
promoters had these big large speakers
that are about call this room
about this why um and so it did write I
wrote to management about that and and
Michael's not here to address this but I
did write to Michael and to Richard as
well and said look where does the
liability land and you know does the
venue have some liability if people
can't see the shows or is it the ticket
Tech that sells the tickets or is it the
promoter and I don't have the answer to
that but it would be helpful to know in
the future I was I wasn't personally
seeking to get the money back but it was
disappointing to pay for two tickets
$180 something do and not see most of
the show yeah I mean it's not uncommon
that there are seats with obscured views
but they're generally recognized uh when
you're purchasing them so what was the
response you had Rex so basically our
role is um hire of the venue so we hire
the venue to the promoter um who then
Works through the ticketing agency to
sell the tickets on behalf of the AB
ility generally will be with the
ticketing agency or the promoter and not
the hirer of the venue y the the other
point that was made and when I sought
response to the queries that you raised
with me which I appreciated getting the
heads up to be able to get the
information prior to here uh is that and
for any member of the public uh if there
are concerns on the night that the that
their viewing is obscured or whatever
they can address that with the ushers at
the time and there is some contingency
available to those ushers even though it
may be be sold out there are a couple of
SE or there are some seats that are
available for for that so so basically
the information I've received and
followup is that it becomes a promoter
ticket ticketing agency responsibility
and generally that is dealt with uh in
the BBY we Clause of the of the terms
and conditions when you purchase those
tickets but can be dealt with after the
fact as well again through those
respective entities not the venue hire
or
Council for that that's a shame though
isn't it because then we could moan
about the Stags if they lose we could
seek compensation you mean we
don't we'll get compensation from the
venue oh that's
sorry they had a great
season
lby did you have anything else I did
just the very last two things actually
uh alen raised the issue of litter um
and and I'm not just talking about odara
you go out around the back end of a city
there's just litter everywhere on the
roads B loads and B loads of not not in
B loads when you pick them up and I've
done some picking up recently and I
think we car and I went about half a
kilometer and got nearly four bags full
of it it's just it's mountains of it so
I don't know where the liability for
that all lies is it something that
Council has a liability for do we want
people to have walking group to go and
pick it up and then there's all the
issues about safety traffic traffic
safety when you're trying to do that
sort of stuff as well I I just yeah the
don't have the answers to all the fun
police have killed a lot of little
service clubs and Scout groups and the
like that that used to do that but it's
a good point there's a a difference no
sorry there are two two ways that it's
dealt with some ways through Council uh
when we're following up on a request for
service but it also it Al is also
possible for police uh if they observe
littering to prosecute
okay and the final thing for me was the
issue of
um um the Donovan Park master plan which
is on um page
174 and this again just reinforces for
the record um the report does that we're
developing a master plan and we're
asking for as ations about what we
should do with Donovan Park and at the
same time we don't really want to know
about where the rby club stays or
doesn't stay and nor do we want to know
about the pathway it go through the
middle past the duck pond um this is all
about the future of the farm so one
breath we're asking the community what
they want to do with that piece of land
but 6 months ago we put it on a a report
for disposal I mean it
just I just don't get that and I don't
get the master plan stuff again but I've
raised it before no it is still out for
consultations for until Friday this week
y I've got pania then Grant then
Evelyn I just want to say that's a great
idea Grant and may around uh just
monitoring the trails and at that and
Bluff but I think if we're going to look
at the bluff Hill one which I think
locals are starting to use a bit more we
also need to be looking at the the glory
track the Mion tracks all those tracks
that intertwin because they are well
used yeah and I think we just need to
make that more
visible thank you I think they're also
covered off in the bluff tourism master
plan yeah I was going to say well we
don't see that much around this table
around the bluff master plan so maybe
there might be some key components that
could be monitored through the activity
report Grant no
you're
um so just um to answer part of the
question that c raised about the um
classification for de accessioning of
materials um which is
the um there is a protocol for
that um anything over $10,000 has to go
to the trust for its decision it's um
but none of those materials that are
being considered for declassification
ification are actually currently going
to PARTA T they are actually stored
elsewhere so is that the question that
you were
raising sure you know I mean they're not
going to the they're not going to the
storage facility no that that wasn't the
issue for me the issue was really more
around around Staffing so I I don't know
how many were at the Museum before I
think somewhere between eight and 10
staff so if we're moving staff majority
of those staff down to the storage
facility or the other the other facility
will we have a period where we need
quite a bit of staff there to do the
work and how long will it take and then
does it mean that we're going to have
another eight or 10 staff sitting in the
museum so we an effect double the
Staffing I think they'll go back to
there'll be some job and sight sharing
in the interum and particularly during
removal and then construction yeah um
but you have collection staff who will
ultimately mostly work from tsy but as
collections are being transported to the
site um then they maybe need to there
for a while just one so I mean um Mr C
be more aware than I am but my
understanding is that there is only one
staff member that is not part of the
collections team at this current point
in time and they don't start till next
year is that is that my understanding
yeah I think we're we we're talking um
talking here over a period of time so
the the needs are quite different that
of what's now to what will be needed in
6 months to 12 months because we're
going to be talking two different
facilities at two different VAR
variations of where they're at in the in
the Journey of both change over but also
needing to keep the the um storage
facility operational and um with the
appropriate resources available they
don't need display staff at the moment
because it's curatorial staff at the
moment except for the um director of
museums corre but I got say that will
evolve as yeah the facility becomes
operational and and that operational
component is obviously still to be
designed developed and constructed um so
we have a bit of that's an important
Point time on our side to work through
the operational requirements of the
Queens spark facility while at the same
time bearding in the um the collection
facility and what is long required the
long term and we still got to work that
through
yeah Rick says yes
Bobby so just just to reinforce what P
was saying I think it would be wise for
us to revisit the master plan for Bluff
somewhere along the line I think there's
a lot of good potential down there that
we're not grabbing hold of yeah so for
we don't know what's happening when we
pull the building down demolition of the
building could the existing Maritime
Museum fit there on the Main Street I
mean I don't have
the I mean and and as P said there's a
there's a huge amount of traffic all
around some of the other tracks I get it
from the M Home Association a lot of
people don't go there because he can't
park up overnight it's difficult um so
so that would come through this
committee so it's only been two years
since we adopted the master plan I'd
really like to take a lead from the
bluff community board so I'm interested
you raise a good point ter it would come
through here once the community board
lifted it up it would come back through
yes yeah p and I pick that up y ex
perfect
answer Alex you thank you you hit the
nail I don't
need okay somebody like to move we
receive the report TR second put that
all in favor against
carried
uh I don't have a px do I excellent I
shall uh thank you for your attendance
close the meeting and we'll be back with
a full council meeting
momentarily